hallo leute wir sind heute in bremen an
der wunderschönen weser und bei uns sind
meine name ist aber dass lea und unsere
heutige wieso de ist ein geschenk und
sogar eine überraschung für eine von
euch einen von euch zuschauern kommt
dass allein
er kommt raus dublin er ist lehrer und
songs and mary's college ja vielleicht
hast du jetzt schon erkannt dass dougan
meint bist lorenz cover na du bist
deutschlehrer in irland an mary college
und woher wissen wir dass deine schüler
munz geschrieben denn sie sind so
begeistert von dir dass sie dich
unbedingt mal über easy german grüßen
wollen wir finden das so toll denn deine
schüler haben sehr begeistert von dir
gesprochen sie haben erzählt dass wir
alle easy german episoden im
deutschunterricht geguckt hat was wir
natürlich vorbildlich und toll finden
und deswegen möchten wir dir auch heute
danke sagen zusammen mit deinem schülern
und der klasse von 2016
wir fragen heute mal die menschen leben
wer ist dein lieblings lehrer und warum
die frage heute ist wer war dein
lieblingslehrer erinnerst du dich noch
da tatsächlich meine deutschlehrerin ja
und warum wir hatten sie als
klassenlehrerin von der siebten klasse
und dann noch mein abitur sie hat sich
halt mega mühe gegeben und alles
mögliche gut beizubringen auch dass wir
gut durch zentraler wie kommen wir der
zweite jahrgang waren glaub ich
wer war dein lieblings lehrer oder die
lieblings lehrerin in deiner schule
frauchen aus oldenburg was hat sie so
als lieblings lehrerin ausgemacht für
dich tun hat sich viel um uns gekümmert
und war auch ziemlich strengen während
der schulzeit aber im nachhinein was
ganz gut ich hatte mein lieblingslehrer
das war mein religionslehrer der war
richtig cool richtig coole geschichten
erzählt
ja ich weiß nicht wer hat immer gut
drauf und hat immer gute noten gegeben
das war mein deutschlehrer in der
oberstufe genau was hat ihn so als
lehrer ausgemacht der war sehr offen der
hat uns einfach schreiben lassen und hat
er keine
regel so vorgelegt und das war super und
wir konnten sehr kreativ sein jeder so
wie es am besten konnte und das war ganz
cool und der hat ja auch so ein bisschen
fürs leben geprägt ich hatte ein
lieblingslehrer der wahl politisch sehr
stark engagiert was ich seinerzeit noch
nicht so drauf hatte aber es war einer
in der klasse der mit ihm auf der
gleichen partei bank gesessen hat und
immer die besten noten bekam weil ich
habe die gleiche sprache wie der lehrer
ja aber ich war etwas neutral und das
war der lieblings sehr aber trotzdem wer
war dein lieblings lehrer oder den
lieblings lehrerin in der schule dr
jochen ziegler
was hat ihn so als guten lehrer
ausgemacht mein volles potential erkannt
als einzige ich hatte ein
lieblingslehrer den fand ich ganz klasse
weil er mein lieblings fächer
unterrichtet hat und die auch gut
unterrichtet hat das format oder das
irgendwie so viel spaß gemacht es immer
durch den klassenraum gehüpft den fand
ich super
und meine andere lieblings lehrerin die
war dann so ein bisschen wie eine mutter
war aber vom unterricht nicht so ganz
stark ganz viel allein arbeiten lassen
aber war ihm von einer person her total
super das waren meine beiden
lieblingslehrer gibt es irgendwelche
witzigen geschichten die die beiden
erzählen könnte
oh ja einige auf der abschlussfahrt in
holland ist er in so eine kraft gefallen
die war aber leider also auf einer
fahrradtour die wir aber leider voller
kuhdung muss dann noch 15 kilometer
zurück fahren zum boot aber klasse typ
ich hoffe es geht ihm gut
witzin den griechen unbedingt unbedingt
also herr dr ziegler
falls sie das irgendwie sehen es geht
ihm gut mir geht es gerade super sitzung
treiben auf der parkbank
viele grüße david war das der
politiklehrer der der sehr fair
das fand ich gut so da war ziemlich fair
und hattest immer geschafft dass man die
sachen aus einem anderen winkel noch mal
sieht also dass man eine andere
sichtweise einnimmt das fand ich gut
mein deutscher ziemlich witzig der
hammer der hatte hier immer viel spaß
und er war ein freund und ich bin lehrer
ja dank der hohen grüne abschluss
gemacht noch mal grüßen das nicht wieder
zurück an unserer schule kommt hätte das
vielleicht dann krise jetzt nur ein
lehrer herr du bist also eine lieblings
lehrerin ist vorüber und die ist halt
sympathischen egal wann man in welcher
situation man schwierigkeiten hat die er
gerne okay was ist oder war euer
lieblings lehrer oder lieblings lehrerin
in der schule mein lieblingslehrer war
glaube ich immer mein sportlehrer mit
dem habe ich mich immer am besten
verstanden bei mir was die
englischlehrerin weil die einfach so
locker drauf war die war er eine
freundin als dass es eine lehrerin war
für mich mit der konnte man immer zum
quatschen und so bei mir was er da die
schulband auch geleitet hat mit dem war
auch relativ schnell auf du später
und da war bis zum abi richtig cool was
willst dann macht generell einen guten
lehrer aus einfühlungsvermögen in die
schüler denke ich also dass man nicht
einfach nur sachen fordert sondern auch
weiß wie man es den schülern beibringen
in deutschland noch mal grüßen sie es
leider gestorben
kurz nach dem abi eine schöne erinnerung
an ihr also das kann ich ganz einfach
beantworten für mich macht einen guten
lehrer aus wenn der lehrer sich nicht so
als lehrer gibt sondern eher so als als
mitschüler bloß trotzdem noch autorität
vermittelt
ja es ist also in dem fall ist es halt
cool wenn dich der lehrer auch im w für
den schüler und für die lern
persönlichkeit interessiert und nicht
sag ich mal alle nur gleich mit weil es
gibt leute die lernen
manche leute lernen schneller manche
leute lernen ganz strukturiert und
manche leute lernen er kreativ und wenn
ein lehrerschaft darauf einzugehen dass
es eben verschiedene persönlichkeiten
gibt in seiner gruppe dann ist das ein
guter lehrer
das war unsere episode für mister carina
vom st mary's college in irland jetzt
nochmal herzliche grüße von deiner
klasse allerdings vor ort wo es bis der
kadaver von douglas auf 2016
das war ein gruß von den schülern wir
hoffen dir und euch allen hat die
episode gefallen
jaja das jetzt bleibt nur noch eine
frage offen wer ist eigentlich dein
lieblings lehrer also mein
lieblingslehrer ist eckig reihe von der
gesamtschule bremen mütter grüßen dich
okay diese episode speziell auch mit
speziellen dank an dich wenn ihr haben
wir heute einen workshop gemacht und
deswegen sind heute hier in bremen
unterwegs
grüße einecke grüße an alle zuschauer
und danke fürs zuschauen bis nächste
woche
und wenn ihr mehr easy german sehen
wollt dann müsst ihr unseren kanal
abonnieren abonnieren